you
in mid December 1965 the Christmas
spirit assumed the tangible format on
salute Air Base South Vietnam here
Operation Christmas star reached a
climax as thousands of pounds of
Christmas gifts donated by communities
and organizations throughout the United
States were unloaded from aircraft for
distribution to all US forces in South
Vietnam planes and personnel of the air
national guard and air force reserve
from states across the nation provided
the cargo space for the special airlift
these boxes of Christmas gifts were
flown to vietnam by the sea 97 of the
California Air National Guard one of the
82 aircraft which took part in the
operation
more than a million pounds of gifts were
collected in the United States with
collection and shipment under
operational control of the Continental
Air Command tonnage which could not be
accommodated by the 82 programmed
flights was scheduled for Surface
Transportation
in Saigon on December 24th as Christmas
Eve approached there was another
expression of the holiday spirit the
scene was the Tontine Hawk orphanage and
other Saigon children not residents of
the orphanage were interested and
somewhat wistful spectators
the party officially began as Santa
Claus and the person of a u.s. master
sergeant arrived carrying a large bundle
of toys he was followed by a cake almost
as large the orphanage had been in
existence only two months its residence
ranged in age from birth to three and
one-half years and this was the first
Christmas party any of them had ever
attended the hosts were men of a u.s.
army replacement battalion stationed
near Saigon
members of the battalion were
voluntarily sponsoring and financing the
orphanage with funds collected by payday
donations and strategically placed
cookie jars even the spectators derived
a vicarious enjoyment the party itself
was sponsored by the replacement
battalion with many of its members
acting as volunteer hosts and they
seemed to enjoy it as much as the
youngsters toys were purchased by men of
the battalion who had previously bought
the orphanage a stove and refrigerator
and were paying the nurses salaries the
battalion chaplain joined in the
festivities this little girl was
spoon-fed her first taste of ice cream
the party's climax drew near as the
chaplain prepared to cut the cake
the cake and the cookies as well were
baked by the battalion cooks on their
own time for these tiny guests at their
first Christmas party the payoff would
come in the eating for their hosts the
reward perhaps was even greater
a few days before Christmas at schofield
barracks in Hawaii a conference was held
by Major General Fred C wayand
commanding general 25th Infantry
Division Brigadier General Glenn d
walker assistant division commander
maneuvers on the left and Brigadier
General Edwin HD saucer assistant
division commander support on the right
when Ted I get the impression from
reading some of this international
traffic that we're getting as well as
the news reports that we may be very
close to receiving a deployment order
here and I think we've got a good echo p
we've been through this many times any
exercises one thing
but I believe we ought to review that
has those peace or deployment and
particularly and get the staff to give
us a minute evaluation of our tactical
readiness and on materialism I'd like to
pay particular attention to these
lessons learned
when what do you think from the tactical
side
pretty well up on them glad you know we
placed a great deal of emphasis on
lessons learned in Vietnam so actually
from an operational point of view I
think we're ready however we continue to
have a small input of replacement which
I think required that we emphasize small
unit at the frame the squad in the
cocoon echelon this of course should
include night barn fire control and
emphasis on the chain of command well I
sure agree with that i think if we only
have two or three weeks left there's a
tremendous amount that we can do on
you're talking particularly if that's
fun I'm wondering about the logistics I
said how do you think we can incorporate
these think there are we incorporate
them in our plan I think we are we've
been as you know cataloging all the
experience that we lay our hands on by
letters and messages can that Nam we've
been cataloging the things we need that
both in the t.o in each category where
we need increases on those stores and on
the non tio in the items I had examples
of increased lumber requirements males
such things as extra hand tools and
things like that and we have been
cataloging and making
in accordance with the decisions of
their commanders and in anticipation of
possible deployment to South Vietnam men
of the 25th Infantry Division the US
Army's reserve force in the Pacific were
sent through a stepped-up training
program designed to prepare them for the
type of combat they could expect in
Vietnam these men undergoing tactical
training in all phases of the 4.2 mortar
illustrate the type of refresher
training they received including such
basics as setting the proper charges
setting charges and giving fire commands
might prove a little different once they
got to Vietnam but us infantry men who
had preceded them there were in
agreement on one basic fact mortars have
been found to be of great value from the
Mekong Delta to the jungles to the
central highlands
training in setting charges was
especially important for new men
assigned to the division as the
refresher training was accelerated the
infantrymen of the Tropic Lightning
division became increasingly proficient
in their mortar drill
if and when the time came for the move
to Vietnam these crews would be ready
also found to be effective in the
jungles swamps and highlands of South
Vietnam is the 105 millimeter howitzer
it has proved especially valuable
because of its capability of being
airlifted by helicopter across
impassable terrain
here a member of a 105 crew laid on the
target
and the weapon was fired
the crew fired several rounds in what
was both training and a demonstration of
their rapid-fire capability
virtually all tactical training would be
repeated at night to prepare the crews
for night combat in Vietnam
as the training mission continued the
batteries executive officer gave a fire
order and a member of the crew recorded
the fire data the divisions 105 and
mortar crews were only two examples of
the tactical training the men of the
25th would undergo up to the day they
received orders to deploy to Vietnam to
deploy major elements of a division from
its home base in this instance Hawaii's
Schofield Barracks to an area of
operations thousands of miles across the
sea is a huge and complex undertaking
involving thousands of men and vehicles
as well as tons of equipment and
materials of war like every other
military unit the 25th Infantry Division
had a carefully worked out SOP to cover
such a deployment however with a move to
Vietnam becoming more and more probable
the divisions commander decided to
conduct a comprehensive readiness
exercise specific objective was to
evaluate and improve the divisions
readiness to deploy its units anywhere
in the Pacific at a moment's notice
however it was an exercise that for the
divisions third Brigade would become an
actual deployment to Vietnam
every unit in the division had it's SOP
one duty of medical personnel was to
check the health records of every man
involved in the deployment records of
men to be deployed had to be separated
from those who would remain
as part of the exercise special jungle
fatigues gas masks and manuals were
packed just as if they were being
shipped to Vietnam
an example of the many logistic problems
involved was the attention given to
specially designed tent frame kits
civilian employees cut lumber exactly to
measure and assembled an enlarged piles
for shipment
Division Officers help supervise
general disaster and the civilian
foreman were also on hand to check in
supervise
the task of cutting assembling and
packing the lumber for the tent frame
kits was finally completed this is how a
tent frame would look when assembled
after deployment studying blueprints
that would serve as guidelines in
erecting thousands of tent frames was
only one of the many painstaking details
required to substantiate the
twenty-fifths motto ready to strike
anywhere anytime looking at the piles of
lumber to be shipped for tent frames it
appeared that not only would they be
ready to strike anywhere anytime they
would also have reasonably comfortable
quarters once they arrived there
Stoneman field at Schofield Barracks is
normally an athletic field however
during the exercise it was used as a
marshaling area for the divisions
vehicles here to the men and their
equipment were assembled boxes of C
rations were given a final check and so
were the men's weapons at least one
infantryman devoted special attention to
an m79 grenade launcher
by now the vehicles were checked gassed
and loaded with equipment the
infantrymen were as ready as they ever
would be some wondered if the exercise
could possibly turn into an actual
deployment and if it didn't they were
sufficiently abreast of the news to
realize that in a few days a real move
could take place
the exercise was realistic enough to
include an actual movement from
Schofield Barracks to the army's docks
in Honolulu Harbor to the tropic
lightning division this was not really a
new experience nor could it be for any
outfit which had long served as a u.s.
army's major reserve force in the
Pacific in 1962 elements of the division
had left Schofield and deployed by air
to Thailand and it was no training
exercise rather it was a show of force
designed to halt a stepped-up communist
offensive in Laos which saw red troops
advanced to the Thailand border
however many of its personnel had joined
the 25th since nineteen sixty-two and to
many a realistic deployment was new
over the years these pineapple fields on
Oahu had seen many a 25th convoy roll by
as the convoy approached Honolulu
commanders remained alert as they had
been throughout all phases of the
exercise for any signs of unit
weaknesses which might hinder tropic
lightnings rapid deployment
finally they reach the US Army
transportation terminal the APCs were
among the first vehicles to be assembled
for loading
the ships were waiting and the vehicles
and equipment were ready the entire
scene gave full meaning to the code name
for the exercise olukai an hawaiian word
meaning to the sea
the 105 millimeter howitzers fired
during a training mission only a few
days ago were fully prepared and lined
up for loading the heavy vehicles too
were fully prepared for a long sea
voyage the entire exercise has reflected
an accurate picture of what actually
happens when an infantry division moves
out for deployment to another area
within a theater of operations now the
loading began first the vehicles were
hoisted on board then came boxes and
crates of rations ammunition and other
supplies and equipment connects
containers also were loaded on board
helicopters were weatherproofed since
they would make the voyage on deck
a few days later at Hawaii's Hickam Air
Force Base c-141 stood ready for the
long flight to Vietnam pallets of duffel
bags were loaded aboard and exercise
holic I was no longer an exercise it was
an actual air deployment of men and
equipment to South Vietnam
deploying to join the fight against the
Viet Cong were approximately 4,000 men
of the 25th divisions 3rd Brigade these
men were fulfilling the 25th soul as the
major immediate reaction force of the
United States Army Pacific once in
Vietnam it was expected that they would
be positioned in the central highlands
near play coup about 250 miles north of
Saigon
Colonel Everett a stout nur commanding
officer of the 3rd Brigade held a final
plane side conference with general
disaster
general Wayans spoke informally with a
departing infant Herman as men of the
3rd Brigade boarded the aircraft which
would take them to the battlefields of
South Vietnam many were aware of the
precise wording of the 25th Infantry
Division's official mission to be ready
for rapid deployment by air or sea
anywhere in the Pacific Command upon
arrival in the objective area be
prepared for immediate conduct of ground
operations ranging from civic actions to
sustain ground combat operations against
hostile forces it was a mission they
were fully prepared to implement
you